Again, you're going to have to read
and tell me which you think is human.
Poem 1: Red flags the reason for pretty flags. / And ribbons.
Ribbons of flags / And wearing material / Reasons for wearing material. (...)
Poem 2: A wounded deer leaps highest, / I've heard the daffodil
I've heard the flag to-day / I've heard the hunter tell; /
'Tis but the ecstasy of death, / And then the brake is almost done (...)
OK, time is up.
So hands up if you think Poem 1 was written by a human.
Hands up if you think Poem 2 was written by a human.
Whoa, that's a lot more people.
So you'd be surprised to find that Poem 1
was written by the very human poet Gertrude Stein.
And Poem 2 was generated by an algorithm called RKCP.
Now before we go on, let me describe very quickly and simply,
how RKCP works.
So RKCP is an algorithm designed by Ray Kurzweil,
who's a director of engineering at Google
and a firm believer in artificial intelligence.
So, you give RKCP a source text,
it analyzes the source text in order to find out how it uses language,
and then it regenerates language
that emulates that first text.
So in the poem we just saw before,
Poem 2, the one that you all thought was human,
it was fed a bunch of poems
by a poet called Emily Dickinson
it looked at the way she used language,
learned the model,
and then it regenerated a model according to that same structure.
But the important thing to know about RKCP
is that it doesn't know the meaning of the words it's using.
The language is just raw material,
it could be Chinese, it could be in Swedish,
it could be the collected language from your Facebook feed for one day.
It's just raw material.
And nevertheless, it's able to create a poem
that seems more human than Gertrude Stein's poem,
and Gertrude Stein is a human.
So what we've done here is, more or less, a reverse Turing test.
So Gertrude Stein, who's a human, is able to write a poem
that fools a majority of human judges into thinking
that it was written by a computer.
Therefore, according to the logic of the reverse Turing test,
Gertrude Stein is a computer.
(Laughter)
Feeling confused?
I think that's fair enough.
So far we've had humans that write like humans,
we have computers that write like computers,
we have computers that write like humans,
but we also have, perhaps most confusingly,
humans that write like computers.
So what do we take from all of this?
Do we take that William Blake is somehow more of a human
than Gertrude Stein?
Or that Gertrude Stein is more of a computer than William Blake?
(Laughter)
These are questions I've been asking myself
for around two years now,
and I don't have any answers.
But what I do have are a bunch of insights
about our relationship with technology.
So my first insight is that, for some reason,
we associate poetry with being human.
So that when we ask, "Can a computer write poetry?"
we're also asking,
"What does it mean to be human
and how do we put boundaries around this category?
How do we say who or what can be part of this category?"
This is an essentially philosophical question, I believe,
and it can't be answered with a yes or no test,
like the Turing test.
I also believe that Alan Turing understood this,
and that when he devised his test back in 1950,
he was doing it as a philosophical provocation.
So my second insight is that, when we take the Turing test for poetry,
we're not really testing the capacity of the computers
because poetry-generating algorithms,
they're pretty simple and have existed, more or less, since the 1950s.
What we are doing with the Turing test for poetry, rather,
is collecting opinions about what constitutes humanness.
So, what I've figured out,
we've seen this when earlier today,
we say that William Blake is more of a human
than Gertrude Stein.
Of course, this doesn't mean that William Blake
was actually more human
or that Gertrude Stein was more of a computer.
It simply means that the category of the human is unstable.
This has led me to understand
that the human is not a cold, hard fact.
Rather, it is something that's constructed with our opinions
and something that changes over time.
So my final insight is that the computer, more or less,
works like a mirror that reflects any idea of a human
that we show it.
We show it Emily Dickinson,
it gives Emily Dickinson back to us.
We show it William Blake,
that's what it reflects back to us.
We show it Gertrude Stein,
what we get back is Gertrude Stein.
More than any other bit of technology,
the computer is a mirror that reflects any idea of the human we teach it.
So I'm sure a lot of you have been hearing
a lot about artificial intelligence recently.
And much of the conversation is,
can we build it?
Can we build an intelligent computer?
Can we build a creative computer?
What we seem to be asking over and over
is can we build a human-like computer?
But what we've seen just now
is that the human is not a scientific fact,
that it's an ever-shifting, concatenating idea
and one that changes over time.
So that when we begin to grapple with the ideas
of artificial intelligence in the future,
we shouldn't only be asking ourselves,
"Can we build it?"
But we should also be asking ourselves,
"What idea of the human do we want to have reflected back to us?"
This is an essentially philosophical idea,
and it's one that can't be answered with software alone,
but I think requires a moment of species-wide, existential reflection.
Thank you.
(Applause)